[Music]
and worse fishing trip ever news this
was submitted by but first coffee a
drunk charter boat captain help
passengers captive for 12 hours with the
guard with a gun is this considered an
act of terrorism because it's like
international waters terrorism a scene
that's piracy right there at home the
captain would like just a long fishing
poles like I'll hook the [ __ ] out of you
you try to run out of here cause if you
look you're right here yeah that's the
pain also it's just like you don't even
have to use a gun you're just like hey
I'll get us lost yeah I'm not gonna jump
off that baby got me they didn't say the
race of the passengers if they were all
black you're then probably like Owens
going in the line yeah we literally
could be 50 feet for the show I lose my
[ __ ] I do a lot of dangerous [ __ ] cuz I
can't swim at all I've jumped off
ravines and I this is away I went I went
scuba diving with no vest
how does be out there that's definitely
like what's up about city's real like
scurry on back but I would be [ __ ] up
if a captain did this to me are you
certified scuba diver no I am NOT I what
do you think of that I think that you
like scuba card really yeah it's right
you still there no no I didn't still
ended oh and it the hard way going
through paddy classes how many hours do
you have to do to get something like
that it was like 20 hours plus online
courses music zero okay you did the one
time was in Hawaii and I'm never again
20 hours in all white it's actually more
it's like 32 hours
eight-hour days yeah it's a lot of time
and why did you do this just to say that
because I wanted to scooter dive and
they only let you do it if you're
certified Oh pulls you to water I'm
always wanted to do that [ __ ] I know you
have to be certified I was like [ __ ] did
you do it yeah did you do it in Hawaii
just so you could do that in Hawaii
once I decide I'm gonna do something I'm
[ __ ] zeroed in right but it's got to
be something good all right did I say
what do the things they really doesn't
dig water heats water what the [ __ ] this
is what he drinks three times like five
of these yeah that's nice man this is
for the whole day oh that's all she
drink usually usually it's like proving
we can't beat the truth of reminders of
why right now Steve peat glows in the
dark like it's purple sometimes it's
purple when it's gotten beat when he's
got a full load as Nicolas like and you
little stick clear that's not healthy
man I call on the dirt so back to this
captain here so this took place in
Florida there were five passengers who
hired this captain named mark and so
they went out for a 12-hour fishing trip
starting at 6 a.m. and once they were
about 60 miles out one of the passengers
carlo asked his 15 year old kid named
Jason to go to the second deck and grab
a beer from a plastic bucket that was
next to the captain which was he was
drinking
the captain was drinking a lot and Oh
Dan told this fifteen-year-old kid to to
put the beer back and so the kid thought
that he was just playing so he's like I
have funny he was like keeps going and
then that's when the captain grabbed him
and ripped off his chain that was around
the team's neck and then that's when
that argument started happening between
all the passengers and so I like that
settled down and the trip continued but
it was obviously like a weird tension in
the air and so that's when the captain
calls up this 25 year old passenger
named Chris to go up and speak with him
and
so when the captain told him I have a
gun and if I want to I will pull I would
put a bullet in each of your heads and
leave you out here so then at that point
they were all just like holy [ __ ] words
like I don't want to die today so they
were just they're all really scared and
was he holding the gun he said yeah how
many five people like five passengers oh
no at that point I'm plotting to take
this fool down five against one well and
if he didn't brandish the weapon I'm
[ __ ] attacking him immediately it's a
[ __ ] mutant he had a 9-mil handgun it
also depends on how far away from shore
you no one knows how to fly the ship at
680 miles xtml that's pretty far I don't
know how to drive a boat I'll figure it
out the passenger started begging the
captain like please we want to go home
but the captain kept drinking and he was
using cocaine fired six or seven shots
in the air he cool he's almost out right
now counting us yes so then that's right
make them shoot some more come more
times yeah but then that's when the
captain appeared to turn around and head
to shore but then that's when the
passengers discovered that he was just
driving in circles and they found out
because of the compass map on their
phone or app on their phone and we could
use their phone and they didn't hit up
you can't call you can't call but the
compass Apple probably work oh that's
the thing they waited or like they were
trying to get reception this whole time
and finally did get within cellphone
range and so that's when they contacted
the police and the US Coast Guard and so
the captain was arrested and as he was
being arrested he kicked the rear door
of a police cruiser nice so they're
saying that they're investigating the
potential like kidnapping the wife is
all belligerent um so they're
investigating what happened on the boat
but he has been charged with boating
under the influence and resisting a long
what about
hostage-taking yeah we got a G on that
ship for just saying nobody going is
going anywhere until I get my [ __ ] right
that is true and they're on the water
right
that's a little bowl yeah
and then this looks like he eats people
that one looks like a pirate he does
little party you see the path y'all go
to regular saying 12 hours it's too
[ __ ] long the fish okay if you can't
get this [ __ ] done four and five and
[ __ ] they might bite okay
twelve hours is too long do you think
it'll take to get to the spot words like
a two-hour spice bars you think so I
don't think it tastes so was just
traveling boats boats are kind of slow
yes I can walk faster than a boat I mean
is it be like it may be possible to fish
invited more than others but usually if
you get like 20 miles off of the shore
you feel pretty good right there
you know what if I want a big old Marlin
then take your ass down to Florida they
are in Florida okay would you go where
you guys got a live debunked damn it
this keeps happening
[ __ ] pants and [ __ ] tourists yeah yeah
oh yeah say [ __ ] kids too I did that
yeah that was second as always there's
usually first a second [ __ ] these kids
that's how I'm all this I just want to
go fishing now that's not your kind of
fun I have a buddy who's yeah but but
it's for tuna right Mandy yeah but it
costs 300 bucks each time you roll oh
it's not gonna give you a discount so
he's not really your buddy 300 bucks
like cuz because he does these fishing
trips right and then only like five
people can roll with him and it cost 300
bucks a head yeah but you're guaranteed
to get stuff cuz he's a really good like
he could find fish guaranteed you get
him acai what well y'all suck the part
of the boat so you gotta pay the captain
he also get the pod again developing for
the gas 300 for five people that it cost
that much 300 per person no I know
there's only five that's actually pretty
cheap because you know when we did our
photo shoot for the hate clap yeah at
the charter a boat similar to that and
it cost like acting like eighteen
hundred dollars just for like a couple
of people it's all stationary the gasp
oh yeah oh yeah he has all the equipment
there Tony so you could just have that's
cool I would do that
you get lunch and all that [ __ ] but like
total oh my god the biggest [ __ ] yeah
yeah biggest fun I always wanted to go
deep-sea fish me too
yeah I forget every year that's why when
you go deep-sea fishing do you think
like God focus knife I spear
Oh God okay what they have is like this
hook because it's so [ __ ] big that
you can't you can't pull it up with with
the string right so they hook the fish
in and they pull it up like this why
don't you go it's like a stick with the
hook oh but you're not in the water
no no but sometimes you need to have a
bat to put it out of its misery before
you can pull it up - are you kidding I'm
serious out of its misery I know you're
flopping all over them like crazy
but you go BAM and then you kill the
fish really quick yeah as soon as you
see its head because you don't want it
to go on the boat and you have this 200
pound fish that's flopping around with
spikes and [ __ ] yeah yeah like a Marlin
or something or tomorrow yeah yeah
I'll cut you up no thanks I don't want
I'm gonna fishing in a long time have
you been deep-sea fishing no no yeah
I've only been on the pier or like a
little lake and then I catch the little
baby fish I'm in fishes I was like a
teenager but I started like super early
like eight I want my first official
rodeo I like eight it was like a little
the same time it started cocaine
no I thought cocaine at six where's the
fishing rodeo it's like where like they
invite you to the state park and
everybody fishes between like everybody
they have age groups that fish between
certain times certain time and whoever
catches the biggest blue gill catfish I
bother that it's tagged and there's a
couple fish stock they stink style they
stocked lakes oh yes I want the biggest
blue gill my first one it was like size
of my hand blue he hasn't uses like this
small that's tight yeah I think ma was
good I'm not really big into seafood
like that I can I don't have to have it
if I never added another day of my life
I'd be fine I like sushi but other than
that I don't yeah absolutely but even
what sushi do I usually I don't get a
traditional I did it like temper balls
and stuff
a temperature guy like I can't eat cold
food like crab lost a dollar that it's
fruit cocktail I needed to be warm from
only thing I cold is like my fruit and
they guys like me don't a bit but if I
freshly grilled like a cot the fish that
you caught that day it's so different
from the market though mom you can't
tell a difference when you eat it
that's like sugar fish if you had sugar
fish yeah I've definitely seen it before
I've just never been I felt like it was
like too bougie for me it's very bougie
I hate all that [ __ ] but the food's good
the bougie restaurants are like always
take like a big wad of money but I dress
like [ __ ] like I wear super short shorts
so my balls show like I made a
reservation for two but it's just me I
like food that's like you're on poker
roll tour they're just in sweats all day
love it oh it's just like I'm headed to
the strip club like no drawers on short
soy sauce no drawers on short shorts I
got smaller stars yeah he's like a 150
just these joggers right here that's
tight I just like I'm out here y'all see
ya that's it the bottle I feel bad like
this is not smart it's not a good idea
[Music]
you